joining us now the author of Clinton
cash the president of the Government
Accountability Institute Peter
Schweitzer Fox News legal analyst Greg
Jarrett I start on the legal side she
stole a primary she funneled money into
a law firm both controlling the DNC and
her funds to pay for a phony dossier and
she now admits it crimes a lot of crimes
this would appear to be an elaborate
clever scheme by Hillary Clinton the DNC
was broke so Hillary bails him out with
20 million but in exchange she gets the
DNC to sign an agreement that she gets
control over their finances their
strategy their support so then they go
out on these joint fundraisers during
the campaign they raise up to a hundred
million dollars and here's the other
deception the states take their share
but immediately kick it back to the DNC
which kicks their share and the state's
share back to Hillary Clinton for her
use that could be a violation of three
laws campaign contribution limits the
finance reporting laws and it looks to
me like money-laundering illegally money
being moved around to look legitimate
I gotta ask where is I've always liked
Jeff Sessions I am now at the I am now
at the limit where is he what is he
doing because there's so much crime so
many crimes we have put the crimes in
play on the screen that you have
identified and you've been a great
lawyer great investigator great
researcher I don't see that the same
attention and effort of known law
breaking is even being followed nice man
Jeff Sessions incompetent attorney
general I think he's being manipulated
by Rod Rosenstein his Deputy Attorney
General and I think he has recused
himself so many times the Trump Russia
case anything related to Hillary that
now he is intimidated too intimidated to
make the right legal move you know when
you wrote Clinton cash number one New
York Times bestseller
I'm proud we had the first interview we
put you on many times Peter I don't
think we ever imagined this bad but it's
worse than bad it's worse than this bad
stealing an election taking over the DNC
admitting to funding the the phony
Russian lies propaganda dossier she
funded the whole thing either through
her campaign or through the DNC she was
controlling now the whole thing she's
admitting the whole thing then the
uranium one deal and you know everyone
in the media says well Hannity why are
you talking about Clinton because we
have a constitution rule of law equal
justice under the law and they're not
living by the same rules as the rest of
us they do whatever they want they smash
blackberries they bleach pit subpoenaed
emails they delete emails and then they
get kickbacks for selling out America
security this is not a game this is not
funny and then poor Bernie Sanders the
sucker sap he is he accepts all of this
and says nothing he covers it up for her
your thoughts yeah I know you're right
Sean I mean look the Clinton message has
always been that you know the attacks on
them are sort of from the right wing
vast right-wing conspiracy can't say
that about Donna Brazile I mean she was
one of their most loyal lieutenants for
a very long time she said she'd never
take the job if she knew yeah yeah and
and here's the thing Sean what do all of
these scandals have in common
money the Clintons have been since
they've been in public life going back
to the days in Arkansas they've been
about controlling money acquiring money
using money as a weapon using money as a
means to power and they really are the
one political machine left at the
national level in American politics I
think they're under assault right now
from the Obama team from the Bernie
Sanders supporters but all of these
things come together as it relates to
the infrastructure of acquiring money
and using money and what they ran into
in in 2008 with Barack Obama and in 2016
were basically populist or popular
campaigns that that defeated their
attempt to buy the nomination and the
election in 2008 and 20
let me go back to Greg after all this
talk about the dossier and all the
denials that's like on the Iranian one
news will break in a minute all denials
all lies and she stole an election and
she says there's a difference between
the dossier she funded Russian lies
propaganda misinformation disinformation
that was widespread to manipulate the
American people and she's braked an
election stolen election well she's
right about that there is a difference
between her pain for the dossier and
Trump Russia so-called collusion but not
the way she means what she did appears
to have been a crime it's a crime to
give money to a foreign national in a
political campaign that's what she did
it's not a crime for Donald Trump jr. to
talk to a Russian lawyer or George
papadopolis to talk to a Russian during
the cases bought this is difference this
isn't oh I've got information do you
want to hear it
this is I'm paying for the false
information it's the exchange of money
that the law prohibits the Trump
campaign there's no evidence there was
an exchange of money it's not a crime to
talk to a Russian but Hillary Clinton it
could be a crime not only paying the
money but then hiding it by filing a
false misleading finance remand they
funneled it through the same law firm
the whole thing oh yeah mark Elias who
represents not just as General Counsel
the DNC he's also a lawyer for the
Hillary Clinton campaign and he
represents the Podesta group or the
Podesta's talk about a conflict of
interest let me go back to you Peter
Schweitzer because we have this new news
on uranium one John Solomon Sarah Carter
gonna be here I want to get your
thoughts Wow because the number one
excuse they have been using it never
left the United States well first of all
we import uranium the idea that we're
going to give 20% of uranium to Putin
never made sense we don't have enough
for ourselves we have to bring in
uranium to this country your reaction to
that yeah no that's exactly right this
is another devastating developments in
the Clinton narrative and look Shawn
let's remember who is Rossa Thom rasa
tahn the Russian state atomic agency is
not like our Department of Energy
Rossa Tom in Russia it controls the
Russian nuclear arsenal it has involved
in nuclear programs in Iran North Korea
and elsewhere so it's not a surprise
it's not a surprise that if you give
them control of uranium assets they're
not going to worry about export licenses
or promises that they made to the Obama
administration about what they were
going to use with the uranium it's just
laughable and there's another reason it
needs to be investigated all right thank
you both